hello there and welcome to conan o'brien
needs a friend a terrific podcast if i
do say so myself i tripped over the word
podcast
and you know what that means it's not a
terrific podcast
you were lying yeah yeah that's that's
true what did i say did i say i'd cast
it sounded like you said pod
chest do you still think you host a show
yeah we've turned this off long ago it
does i know so what am i doing we do
this all for your ego this thing never
sees the light of day that's funny
because if you knew how many people come
up to me every day and shout buzz words
from this podcast
like podcast there yeah that'll be a new
one podcast conan like the
podcast and i won't even know what
they're talking about i've had people
recognize my voice yeah that's really
cool that doesn't matter they heard you
across a room okay matt no i'm not i'm
no what are you trying to say right
they've heard you from three counties
over okay well i'm sorry you will
recognize your voice you have a uh loud
you're a loud woman yes i am a loud
woman and yes they have heard me from
across the room okay you're one of the
ladies i got upset at you but you're
totally right you're one of the loudest
people i've ever met okay seriously you
are very loud i know a friend of yours
is even louder than i am
i know the friend you're talking about
one of my good friends yes he's he's
quite loud yeah i think you blow him out
of the water
i grew up in a very loud environment i
come from a very loud people and we are
loud yeah yeah okay that's fine
just like so defensive so why would you
say that it's not true because i feel
like you're coming at me from like a
very judgmental
i think it's great if you're ever lost
in the forest i'll find you instantly
okay you know what i mean i'd like to go
hiking with you just because i wouldn't
need a whistle huh you could just start
in a normal conversational tone
saying hmm maybe we should get lunch and
park rangers would hear you nine miles
away okay i will say that i'm recording
at home but i have your microphone here
and i'm picking you up for this podcast
all right this is fun okay this is fun
this is so fun
wait you're just picking up her voice
from a microphone that's sticking out
your window yes
it's traveling from from hollywood to
pasadena yes wow and it's comes in
perfectly fine sona i think you're you
know this i think you're terrific i
think you're terrific i hate this what
are you talking about i don't know what
you're going to say but i hate it so
much you're a good friend you're a great
assistant you're you're
loyal are so loud you know what's funny
is oh god just
i know i was gonna say this is years
after me controlling it because people
have called me out on it so much if i
really want to talk normally this is it
oh wow yeah this is my actual voice that
i want that i have to subdue because
people like you stop it cars are
crashing right now
because people listen to this while
they're commuting and right now people
are reaching for the volume button and
their cars are going off the embankment
the windows in my office just shattered
um she says i hate it here so much what
do you do because you have twins now
that need to be put to bed i bet you're
very quiet when it's time for them to go
to sleep i'm quiet and then it gets loud
in my house just because there's so many
ethnic people just walking in these
people you're related to yes
it's an it's a small world ride at your
house yeah it's awful like well just put
them down there'll be a noise machine
and then the door will open okie will
start barking people will be like what's
going on here and then like you know
then they're awake is this your parents
is this your everyone it's my parents
it's tax parents it's my you know
cousins my brother and did then do they
play uh their ancestral instruments how
does it okay
i can't you can't i don't know what's
isn't there a drum that the armenians
have an and a fife what is it it's a
jute bag and a duduk a what a doombag
that's the drum and then
call us
is that true did you have a dumbback and
a doodoo at your wedding i remember
there were
was there a dumb buck and dude at your
wedding yeah when we first walk into the
wedding i remember there was an
accompaniment i thought someone had
backed into some trash cans i'm sorry
you're listening to dumb back and dude
hook in the morning that's yeah guess
what that's the
in yerevan in armenia that is the wacky
drive time show it's tuned
come back
[Applause]
bang bang bang bang bang
with sonum obsession broadcasting live
from los angeles without a mic
they can hear me in armenia yes okay i
just wanted to make sure they don't
think you ever left yeah people were
like they just said he's done very well
she never went to america i heard her
this morning well it's jumbo i love dumb
i was bored in this country were you at
all tempted to name your twin sons
i would not at all ever no
come to mama i hate when i teach you new
things don't matter
because then you just do this all the
time
i bought you a bicycle build for two
dumbbell put that back oh look the rap
sign
i don't see it it's right there nope i
don't know i was just that was just i
was fanning myself that's not a website
all right we'll look for
our other podcasts we'll be broadcasting
the morning in armenia
those two wild men are going to shake
things up in their armenian drive time
radio